now this will seem like it comes a
little bit out on that field so forgive
me this this idea fits at the start of
both this topic integration and also
series of sequences in fact if you
remember back to some of the past papers
I gave you for last term's exams okay
you might be like hey what's this
serious stuff that's in there it used to
be and if you even have a look at yellow
fits
series and sequences used to be done
earlier in the course and so this can
fit as an introduction to that okay
we're doing it in
what is summing the Hitchin let me write
them down for you and then we'll explain
it now I've um I've drawn this for you
before okay so I'll give you a simple
example and then we'll talk about it
okay so what is Sigma notation it's just
a shorthand way of writing down a song
that's all it is
in fact Sigma right it's a Greek letter
okay and it's the closest approximation
we have to s right so it's s for some
basic way okay so it's adding up a whole
bunch of things which is what a series
we'll get to that soon as well but what
does it look like it shares a lot in
common with function notation okay so
function notation is something like this
right
f of X equals you know X cubed minus 3x
or something like that okay so you're
like look here's a function right and
you can put values into it like 105 or
children right and this is the rule that
everything follows okay in just the same
way the rule then every term that I'm
going to add up here follows this kind
of shape okay so that's kind of like my
function now what's this stuff over here
it tells you how many terms you're going
to have to put into this function okay
and which terms they are right so here
I'm going to start at N equals 1 and
then I'm gonna count up and only goes in
integers
okay when we count up until I get to
four and then I stop
that's all that means okay so in this
case it would be 1 squared it's my first
month 1/2 squared plus 3 squared plus 4
squared that's all nothing mythical
about it okay so this would be 1 plus 4
plus 9 plus 16 which is that's it okay
so seamen that's all it is it's
important to get there because it's
integers right it's incrementing up each
time and you can start any way you like
of why does it go in place to stop zero
is a common place to start but you can
stop from any way you can stop from say
and equals just let's change that up
let's make the K you can make it any
letter you like okay equals let's say
minus 2 let's do something simple like
that
okay now strictly speaking this n in
this case you want to write it down it's
not
it's called a dummy variable what Scott
you sort of don't the web dummies using
a lot of different context to be
completely different things but
essentially what it means is this cave
doesn't it doesn't do anything really
it's just standing in for the numbers
but the numbers are what I'm after
okay so in this case what would it be
it'll be minus 2 1 2 plus minus 1 okay
hey by the way what's this son so props
you can have any fire you know if I made
that if I did - out the front here it'll
be a negative so it seems like a pretty
simple thing and it is ok but I just
didn't want to introduce it to you in
the context of explaining something else
now